oh sure he's off today and here's what's
going on here's that pre dawn's early
light Alex was talking about this is
from our camera on top of the Red Rock
Resort way out on the west side of town
Charleston and the 215 looking out to
the east
sunrise officially at 523 this morning
79 is the official temperature at
McCarran but let's check in on your
neighborhood temperatures here in a
couple of minutes no wind advisory for
Las Vegas but for western Clark County
including Indian Springs most of Nye
County including prom parts of scout
California Lincoln County and a lakewood
advisory from 1:00 until 11 we're all
under a red flag warning this starts at
11:00 this morning runs till 11:00
tonight you combine a low humidity high
temperatures and strong gusty winds and
you have the potential for increased
wildland fire danger high pressures
getting pushed out that's where the wind
is going to come from so over the next
couple of hours we're going to start
jumping by tens I mean we're already at
79 will at least be in the mid 80s at
9:00 mid 90s at noon topping triple
digits going for I have 102 today and 99
at 6:00 p.m.